Draw a circle and label the
radius, diameter, center,
and the circumference.
Let me draw a circle.
And it won't be that
well drawn of a circle,
but I think you get the idea.
So that is my circle.
I'm going to label
the center over here.
I'll do the center.
I'll call it c.
So that is my center.
And I'll draw an arrow there.
That is the center
of the circle.
And actually, the
circle itself is the set
of all points that are a fixed
distance away from that center.
And that fixed distance
away that they're
all from that center,
that is the radius.
So let me draw the radius.
So this distance right
over here is the radius.
That is the radius.
And that's going to be the
same as this distance, which
is the same as that distance.
I can draw multiple radii.
All of these are radii, the
distance between the center
and any point on the circle.
Now, a diameter just goes
straight across the circle,
going through the center.
From one side of the
circle to the other side,
I'm going through the center.
It's essentially two
radii put together.
So for example, this
would be a diameter.
You have one radii, than
another radii, all one line,
going from one side of
the circle to the other,
going through the center.
So that is a diameter.
And I could have
drawn it other ways.
I could've drawn it like this.
That would be another diameter.
But they're going to have
the exact same length.
And finally, we have to think
about the circumference.
And the circumference
is really just how far
you have to go to go
around the circle.
Or if you put a
string on this circle,
how long will that
string have to be?
So what I'm tracing
out in blue right now,
the length of what I'm tracing
out, is the circumference.
So right over here, that
is the circumference.
And we're done.